Michael and I worked on it was faster
plastering solvers so that project was
masterminded by Richard pang who
actually introduced Michael me in an
academic context we've met a couple
times before at Facebook and that
various programming competitions but
this is the first time we actually sort
of got to talk and work over a longer
period of time and the project was about
trying to just take the current fastest
Sebastian solver which was at the time
due to CUDA similar in pang and try to
make it faster and Richards had a pretty
clear vision of how to do it even sort
of over a year before the before we
actually got the result and and it was
divided into two parts where we had to
work on sub-cabinet I'll probably
properties have graphs and we had to
work on linear algebra an optimization
and that was Michael's last year of
undergrad at MIT so it was actually I
think he started working on it a bit
before the summer before his last year
of undergrad and for me it was right
about the side of my PhD at Carnegie
Mellon
so we started talking while I was still
in Poland and we collaborated remotely
on faster lobsters spanning trees which
were a tool we use for applicants always
and we got a result there together with
Gary Miller and changing sue and Richard
and then we we spent some time working
on this problem and and looking forward
at at CMU or Michael was
visiting Gary for the summer so actually
I remember Michaels office at CMU so he
was given an office for visiting
academics and it wasn't a very nice
office you know it was it was served
this small thing with no windows
but Michael really found one very nice
property of it so he was very happy with
the office so you know now that Michael
really thrived when talking to people he
really found out stimulating and and
enjoyed it very much and and he really
liked talking to Gary that they really
had an amazing connection and you know
the problem was that Michaels office was
on the sixth floor and Gary's office was
on the eighth floor and and and so it
was you know problematic to see if Gary
was around but actually there was a big
open space in CMU so let me wrap you so
Gary's over here there was a balcony
here and then there was this you know
painfully long staircase here and an
open space here so essentially if you
wanted if you wanted to see if Gary was
in
you can just see whether his arrows up
and because Gary always skip Caesar open
when he's in the office well the problem
was you couldn't really do this from
this open area here right because you
would stand here and you would not be
able to see whether it are open so
Michaels office was here so I said
multiple times Michael get out the key
and walk into his office and walk right
back to his desk there's good easily see
from his chair
what there guy he was in oh I found it
really funny yeah so let me say a bit
about the problem worked and so hey I
want to talk too much about the the
whole problem I will tell only about the
issue that really took us I would say
all the time after we have or at least
on the on the second part of the paper
that we worked on together with Richard
Rasmus and Anna prowl and okay so the
basic approach for the problem was to
just to solve linear systems on graphs
using
preconditioned iteration based on a the
pre-conditioner being a specified
version of the graph so
the basic idea would be you would have
your current solution X and you would
replace it with
right so this is essentially so if H was
identity right so if you had a simple if
you use no predinner that will be just
grading descent and - it's just great in
descent with on on a tree result which
would have to be well conditioned so
if you just a typical way to proving
these things work is you take the so
let's say you're looking for the optimal
solution X - so you'll tip you typically
be bounding the distance between your
current solution and X - in L norm and
if you know that the condition number of
H relative to l0 is actually low so you
actually have a good pre-conditioner in
the classical sense then this is
actually very easy to prove
you just write this out and you will get
some terms that look like that that will
say that sort of your next say this is I
plus 1 or maybe t plus 1 I would say
that
your next distance looks somewhat like
the previous one
-
now you will get some terms that look at
each universe so the bulk of your
reduction will be here you will get
something like
and then you'll get a similar term alpha
squared times a similar time with H
inverse L H inverse I won't do the full
commutation here but essentially if you
know that H and L are close then these
terms are pretty easy to bound and
Richards okay and also the way we
actually obtain this specifier H in in
in previous algorithms is we take a
lobster spanning tree of the graph which
is essentially a graph that has the
property that any well let's say any
remaining edge of the tree has lost
stretch with respect to it and and then
we sample a bunch of additional edges
and add them to a preconditioner so then
if you sample enough edges through
matrix intersection violence it's pretty
easy to show that H is actually
spectrally close to L and and and these
things become very easy to bound so
Richards idea was that maybe because of
the way we construct this
pre-conditioner we don't we don't
actually need to sample as many edges as
to be able to say that these things are
specially close maybe what we should be
looking at instead is just looking at
this expression directly and just look
at when it decreases in expectation
because if this is if this is if the
right hand side or if this expression if
the if this distance is just smaller in
expectation by a constant factor then we
know we're going to solve that problem
quickly regardless of it being true
always and so
Richard put Michael
Rasmus Anna and me on a quest of trying
to figure out how to how to bound this
term so actually the bounds for H
inverse itself just proving that so what
you'd like to prove actually is you'd
like to prove that if you sample H by
taking a loss you're spanning tree and
adding a match of edges to it then for
any vector it will be true that it's
somewhat close to and you'd like to
prove that this extra part which is H
inverse L age
is not so large
if you obtained bounds of this earth
then you can set alpha appropriately and
you're going to and they're going to
know you're making progress so this is
actually not that hard to show so
actually Richard shop they've grave a
proof of this himself or some particular
sampling scheme and so what most of our
attention focused on was proving this
the about for his second or determined
you know it was something I worked on
for quite a few months and it was it was
hard I I have yeah it was actually like
one of the first problems I working like
Adam and he was sort of the first
problem I really got to grind my teeth
on and and and and sort of we had a
bunch of the time is based on writing it
out and and trying to you know put
different inequalities in different
places and and maybe something will
stick and and it was really proving out
to be quite hard and Michael who who we
call operated a funder and the
constructional search finding trees
before he sort of he started his first
is his last year of undergrad at MIT he
I think took a break from from this
problem for for a month or two and then
came back and
first of all he was he was sort of
unhappy with the proofs we had for for
this all right so he didn't really start
up thinking about about bounding the
second order term which was not not
obvious to anyone but but he really
wanted to understand these things so so
the proofs we had were sort of ad hoc
and combinatorial and she really wanted
to get a good understanding of you know
why we can really expect the inverse of
the others funny funny funny funny
sample specifier to be to be similar on
any vector to the to the the original
graph
and so the notation we would typically
use then is you know if you're only
worried about proving these problems you
can you can just assume that L is
identity which will simplify things
quite a bit
so then
we will okay so then really whatever
problem is is we have
we have a bunch of
vectors
some to identity so this will be sort of
missile correspond to edges in our graph
if the property that
so they all have stretch less than
epsilon with respect to T which is a
spanning tree but we don't really care
it's a tree here is just some matrix and
what we want to prove is that if we take
T and then we and and let's say there is
they go from 1 to M what you want to
prove is that if we take the 3t and we
add random edges from here really only
has to add a constant factor of them in
order to get a good approximation here
which will allow us to recurse
[Music]
okay so Michael
so
Michael started up thinking about how to
how to really how to really get to the
bottom of this equality so trying to
understand what happens when you move
that with the move the first-order
universe and so let's say we have some
sample H I that is obtained after
sampling I of these edges so we sample
them just let's say it's actually always
equal to epsilon please
so we're example we sample this edges
uniformly with replacement we have some
H I and then we wonder okay so how does
how does how will expression V transpose
H I inverse V change after we add the
one additional edge where I try okay so
first angle said is imagine instead of
adding the actual edge to H I we add
sort of the expectation of what we would
add alright so the expectation of what
we would add is just one over m times
identity because we have M edges or some
to identity so then proving proving a
bound for this proving that this is
actually smaller than H I is quite
simple so and we can we can actually
show that this is
yes so this should be less than one over
1 over V transpose H I inverse V
here we'll just have
[Music]
right okay
yes so then we'll have plus M I believe
-
a little bit since I'm looking at her
I'm giving the proof from the unrefined
original Michael note from the date of
invention which was refined many many
times afterwards but I really think the
idea he had there was it was very nice
and used some insight into him how he
came up with a solution anyway there is
a lot of inverses here okay but anyway
I'm sure you can believe me this is not
a very hard expression to bound what is
interesting is and what really was in
Michael Wars himself it was a key idea
to the to twist solution is that so this
is what will happen if you had the
forehead and here idea was saying well
what happens if instead of adding a full
edge I just add a I just think of adding
it continuously right so I started with
my spicy fire and then I add instead of
it surviving at the edge at once I add I
had it linearly it defines the function
f of X where X goes from 0 to 1 as this
so yeah at F of 1 we know we'll actually
we have made some progress with regards
to our original specifier and
yes and the idea is that this function f
of X is actually convex with regards to
X so it has an increasing derivative
which actually means that because we can
bound this expression for x equals to 1
we can bound the derivative of x at 0 so
we can actually say that F prime of 0 is
right is at most F of 1 minus F of 0
right and actually ok so f of 1 question
I was meeting is actually the harmonics
am there Michael count kind of the
previous score and 1 over m and harmonic
sum is just
the inverse of the sum of inverses so
this is
and now okay
and now the very nice part is that the
so this is the derivative of sort of
adding the entire graph to our current
graph but actually this derivative is
equal to the sum of derivatives of what
would happen if I took a random edge and
added it to my current specifier alright
so if instead of I in this expression I
had only some single edge and I try to
add that I try to add that and then look
at how this how this V transpose
specifier inverse V changes if I'm only
looking at the derivative at zero I can
actually I can actually can actually say
that that derivative that this
derivative is the sum of those
derivatives it's actually very nice
because if you try to look at this terms
directly so so after you take a discrete
step it's pretty hard to say something
to say something interesting
so the idea okay
so then we can actually we can actually
get the bound on
we can actually get a bound on H inverse
based on that but there is one very
beautiful consequence of this of this
more principled way of looking at at
this problem and that is that you know
this F prime of zero that we are looking
at if you actually compute its value
it's going to be just it's going to be
roughly 1 over m times V transpose H 2
minus 2v right and so we have bout we
have proved that this thing is that this
thing is is not too large and and we
actually know that because because this
function is convex we know that if we
sum we sum the values of F prime of 0 as
as we go with H I over over a large
period we know that the sum of all these
derivatives is bounded by some is
bounded by the solo progress that we
made and so we can actually we can
actually use this fact to to get a bound
on the on the second moment of our over
specifier and I think that's really
actually really cool how Michaels desire
to just understand the the first part
the the first order approximation over
specifier has led to just solving the
whole problem
and
there is any extra time I might I might
other conjecture that we worked on with
Michael for for for all the time that we
were together CMU and later and we have
never really solved but Michael was very
excited about it sometime and and that
the conjecture is the existence of
spectrally supported spanning trees with
constant tall stretch so actually the
question so okay I don't have extra time
but okay okay well okay
[Applause]
oh sorry yeah so thank you so the
conjecture is so we now drew to Abraham
and Haman that if you have a graph you
can find a low stretch spanning tree
with total stretch of M of H of M log n
log log n and now it turns out that if
you saw the director he has a very stern
property in that it's actually a sub
graph of the graph so instead you might
only want the tree to be a to be
spectrally supported by the graph so
just spectrally less and then the graph
is a matrix so if you want that it's
immediately you know not too hard to
just to you can just apply any
specification algorithm specify the
graph first and you can get a tree with
a low stretch say n log n log N and you
can additionally use let's say you can
introduce Steiner vertices and you can
actually prove that you will need to the
standard vertices for the full
conjecture so let's say we only want to
grab that respect we supported by our
graph and it can have more vertices we
just want to be able to sure complement
them out in order to get a graph that
spectra closed on our graph and let's
say we want a tree like that it's very
easy to show you can get that treat to
have stretch and log N and that
conjecture is that you can get always
the droll it exists at the tree of total
stretch and oh man so we had this nice
thing going on for a month or two where
we would come up for examples and and
then mostly michael would try to find a
way of constructing trees for that party
or family of graphs it's a very
entertaining source of puzzles you can
come of all sorts of weird graphs yeah
so what the conductor is still
unresolved I think if you would bet he
would bet that they exist
but I I mean I also believe that they
exist so maybe we didn't find anyone so
there's a reception outside so
[Applause]